il est indéniablement nécessaire que les
victimes soient mieux accompagner et
informer et ce même avant de faire une
première déclaration à la police
j'ai l'espoir que d'autres options soit
bientôt offerte aux victimes pour les
aider dans le processus de guérison que
ce soit par la médiation la terrifie la
justice réparatrice ou la création des
tribunaux spécialisés
la décision était rendue aujourd'hui
gilbert rozon a été déclarée donc pas
des accusations de viol et d'attentât à
la pudeur pour des événements qui
seraient survenus il ya quarante ans
deux invités jean claude hébert avocat
criminaliste
et si l'une lacerte lamontagne juge à la
retraite de la cour du québec à la
chambre criminelle et pénale et avant
d'être juge d'un master ii vous étiez
vous-même criminaliste donc des sujets
que vous avez souvent abordés d'abord
tous les deux d'abord un premier
commentaire et je pense que je le ferai
à partir d'un des extraits du jugement
si vous lui permettez notamment le
tribunal et je vous le dis je vous le
site que la juge hébert le tribunal
tient à souligner le courage dont a fait
preuve
ab donc là la plaignante qui a demandé
donc qu'elle soit désormais identifiée
il rappelle que le verdict
d'acquittement ne signifie pas que les
incidents reprochés ne se sont pas
produits c'est elle qu'on vient
d'entendre alors madame lacerte votre
premier constat la lecture de ce
jugement ben moi je trouve que ce qui
est intéressant c'est que le jugement
refus tout l'historique de désagréger en
fait de la loi en matière d'agression
sexuelle et je pense que c'est important
dans un contexte pour démontrer
l'évolution qu'il y ait eu est aussi ce
qui est intéressant dans le jugement
c'est que effectivement elle analyse les
deux versions et route ans et elle est
notes de courage de la plaignante de
dette ou d'avoir dénoncé de s'être
présenté à la cour d'avoir subi les
contre-interrogatoires de contrer la
tour des avocats
et elle elle replace aussi dans le
contexte d'un procès criminel c'est quoi
un procès criminel c'est quoi le faire
d'autres preuves la présomption
d'innocence est la conviction hors de
tout doute raisonnable
alors c est je pense que j'ai un cours
de droit à lire le jugement
ouais c'est un cours de droit en fait
oui tout à fait et mémé qui quittent
accessible oui
en même temps jean claude hébert on va
donner un autre extrait du jugement si
vous voulez bien parce que au coeur au
coeur de ces décisions là qui sait ce
qu'on cantillon suivez les réseaux
sociaux les gens veulent à peut-être eu
du mal à comprendre c'est qu'elle croit
la victime il ya des imprécisions mais
elle fait bénéficier
gilbert rozon du doute raisonnable et
dans l'esprit des gens c'est peut-être
pautler l'enjeu c'était un autre extrait
qui est le tribunal ne peut pas priver
monsieur rozon du doute raisonnable sur
la question de la crédibilité
et ce même si sa version paraît moins
plausible que celle de habite dans la
même charrette même si le tribunal ne
croit pas à la version des faits donnée
par le sur auzon celle ci soulève tout
de même à d'autres raisonnable alors
expliquez nous jean claude hébert qu'est
ce que ça veut dire
on croit madame des imprécisions le
témoignage de monsieur rozon est
critiqué mais bénéficie quand même du
doute raisonnable
on est devant toi et si selon vous entre
débats s'annoncent toujours délicat
quand formule ces principes là c'est
délicat de choisir les mots appropriés
et si vrai c'est vrai j'ai eu la même
réaction quand j'ai lu la base même si
le tribunal ne voit pas la version des
faits donnée par monsieur opposants
celle ci soulève même un doute
raisonnable deuxième réflexion c'était
savent pas nécessairement vouloir dire
qu'elle n'a pas vu du tout monsieur
rozon ce que semble dire la juge ici
quand on regarde l'ensemble de son
jugement
c'est que son histoire ses explications
vu par une personne raisonnable sont
plus 100 sans koné la certification que
c'est la vérité authentique c'est
plausible et elle s'explique un petit
peu avant pourquoi revient cette
conclusion-là jugé belzile ozon c'est un
tempérament d'un personnage qui a
tendance à exagérer
et la description des faits autrement
dit liam est plus qu il en faut pour
arriver à s'expliquer devant le tribunal
bon elle dit est ce que c'est c'est
suffisant pour que je balaie du revers
de la main
l'ensemble de son témoignage
manifestement non a dit il reste quand
même au bout de la journée lors que son
explication est plausible un sens que
c'est possible que ce se soit passé
comme il le dit et là je suis obligé de
le faire bénéficier du doute raisonnable
c'est de la faire vous avez vous avez
certainement jugé dès qu il y avait des
versions contradictoires et vous aviez
eu à évaluer la crédibilité on l'a jugé
bert ici disait quelque part c'est pas
un concours de crédibilité ça de décider
si une personne écoute si la couronne ne
remplit le fardeau de la preuve je danse
de tout doute raisonnable
et peut-être que les principes en cause
sont mal compris par par certaines
personnes
je pense qu'effectivement l'exercice que
l'on fait en fait qu'un juge fait c'est
de l'analyse et de regarder la
crédibilité et la fiabilité des
témoignages et vous et moi on n'a pas eu
l'opportunité d'être dans la salle de
cours et d'entendre et d'entendre
effectivement et de voir la plaignante
témoigner également l'accusé témoigne
alors je pense que c'est vraiment une
fête
le juge qui entendent qui entend qu'ils
voient les témoignages à jour j cela est
ni n'a pas à choisir entre la version de
la plaignante la version de l'accusé
doit se demander s'ils sont là elles
d'entre eux dans ce dans ce que si elle
croit la plaignante elle a des doutes
sur le témoignage de l'accusé mais leurs
gardes dans l'ensemble de la preuve et
lui fait bénéficier du doute raisonnable
lors elle applique les critères sont
énoncées par la cour suprême à savoir
les froisse est que la cour suprême lui
demande d'appliquer dans ce genre dans
l'est dans les codes des versions
contradictoires et vous savez les quads
versions contradictoires il y en a en
matière d'agression sexuelle il ya là
matière de violence conjugale
il y en a aussi dans d'autres procès
criminel c'est sûr qu'en matière
d'agressions sexuelles et de violences
conjugales
ça se passe plus dans un en fait dans un
cadre d'intimité
vernin peut-être à d'autres à d'autres
des knicks mais ça reste quand même que
les critères appliqués sont hélas la
juge les paragraphes 40 avait 50 par le
prendre front dans le fond les mythes et
stéréotypes selon lesquelles les femmes
ne sont jamais cru d'une certaine
manière mais avant dofus alors ce que je
vais vous citer ceux ci arrivent au
paragraphe 56 et elle dit ainsi le mot
d'ordre croire la victime qui est
associé au mouvement moi aussi ne pas sa
place en europe criminels prendre -qui
que la plaignante dit la vérité et
imposer la cuisine de démontrer que ce
n'est pas le cas est contraire à la
présomption d'innocence
jean claude hébert ces canaux aussi dans
l'incompréhension ou la perte de
confiance et qui voudraient y voir cette
règle de la présomption d'innocence ne
pas s'appliquer que les victimes
devraient être cru à tout prix ouais il
dit une chose qui est certaine
et il a raison on peut se baser sur
l'ensemble des jugements qui sont rendus
en semblable matière dans l'hypothèse où
la juge hubert n'aurait pas cru
fondamentalement l'histoire de monsieur
rozon en son âme et conscience lé repos
lui le choix que de se tourner de
l'autre côté de regarder comme disait
céline tantôt l'ensemble de la cram
parce que deux autres témoins
bien sûr la prière et la dame son ami
qui a pas dit beaucoup de choses mais
qui a apporté certains faits et voir si
c'est ce morceau de drap blanc à charge
étaient suffisants pour justifier une
conclusion de culpabilité mais à partir
du moment où la juge dit l'histoire de
rose en jeu pas certain que je vais la
balle est à 100% mais il s'est quand
même plausible son récit et même si on
peut avoir des pentes esi là dedans des
choses qui me paraissent un peu exagéré
je peux pas les écarter totalement et
c'est là que cing l'obligation pour la
juge d'accorder le bénéfice de monsieur
rauzan